Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg spent hours
on Capitol Hill today taking questions
from senators about Facebook's role in
the 2016 an election in an American
society more generally we'll talk to one
of the senators who was there and spoke
to Zuckerberg and more broadly what it
meant but first Brett Larson an anchor
at Fox news headlines 24/7 who covers
tech for our show has the big moments
from today Brett it was quite the day
Tucker Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
checked in with Congress today for day
one of hearings and we learned a little
bit about the inner workings of the
social media giant one thing we heard
repeatedly was exactly what Facebook is
and is not what you think of is the
Facebook service right that's everyone
has control every single time if they go
to share that they could delete that
data anytime they want full control the
majority of the data
yeah but sharing everything
not so much mr. Zuckerberg would you be
comfortable sharing with us the name of
the hotel you stayed in last night no I
think that may be what this is all about
your right to privacy the limits of your
right to privacy and how much you give
away yeah but with 2.2 billion users and
in the wake of concerns about more than
80 million users having their data
stolen by political consulting firm
Cambridge analytic is Facebook your only
choice if I buy a Ford and it doesn't
work well and I don't like it I can buy
a Chevy if I'm upset with Facebook
what's the equivalent product that I can
go sign up for well there's the second
category that I was going to talk about
or something that categories I'm talking
about is a real competition you face of
course you don't think you have a
monopoly all right certainly doesn't
feel like that to me okay well there is
also concerns Tucker about First
Amendment rights and just what control
the social media giant has over what you
see say and share you say that you have
15 to 20 thousand people working on
security and content review do you know
the political orientation of those 15 to
thousand people engage in content review
no senator we do not generally ask
people about their political orientation
when they're joining the company you
know senator Ben Sasse asked a similar
question about censorship on the site
and CEO Mark Zuckerberg said the speech
they censor is anytime someone pushes to
hurt others senator sass was also
concerned about addiction to the social
media site as a dad do you worry about
social media addiction as a problem for
America's teens well my hope is is that
we can be idealistic but have a broad
view of our responsibility and Tucker we
will get more from Zuckerberg tomorrow
when he sits down for day two he has
certainly been very frank in his
responses and a little obtuse about
specifics which made the lack of
understanding of exactly how Facebook
works and our understanding of it
very clear thanks to that but appreciate
it thanks